division survival mode is like
officially out today yeah the second of
three planned DLCs came out today and
they had teased it previously and it's
actually been available for on test
servers on PC for a little while so
Aaron Sampson and previously been on the
show to talk about it but it's actually
out today like it is available publicly
as of like midnight last night it for
Xbox though
yeah Xbox and PC ps4 is coming in like a
couple weeks or maybe even a month
something like that yeah for whatever
reason there's an exclusivity deal so
yeah all DLC comes first xbox pc so xbox
pc players you can jump in ps4 players
you have to wait around a little longer
yeah we've like you said we brought
Aaron on we detailed a little bit like
how Ubisoft has been trying to like
keeping like pumping blood into division
since it release and like react in some
ways and this seems like it's I mean
aside from the update 2.4 or whatever it
was that actually like like did a lot of
quality of life improvements don't quote
me on that number I think that's good
but um now like servo mode is very much
reworking what the division actually can
be in some circumstances so you played
what about an hour now of it today you
couldn't get into matches for a while
yeah it's well that's that's it's a
whole long story but I did finally get
in and I did finally actually get to
play a little bit so what's really
interesting I mean as you pointed out
the division has changed quite a bit
over the past eight or nine months since
the game originally launched in I
believe March Ubisoft has done a lot to
improve the core experience loop and to
add on to the existing experience I
think because a lot of players grew
extremely frustrated just with a lot of
things that the game does mean even
outside of the bullets punch enemies
that's an easy thing to point to if this
is annoying why does the game do this
there were plenty of other bigger issues
as well so even even with the DLC even
with things like incursions things like
that it was so easy to feel like the
deck was just stacked against you like
there was nothing you could do as a
player to succeed and it just became
this you know meaningless grind that
didn't even feel rewarding I mean some
people really like the grind Eric Taylor
really likes the grind but unlike the
division the reward wasn't really there
so that brings us to survival which is
essentially a completely standalone mode
like you when you start a survival match
you have nothing or well you don't you
don't have nothing but you have what the
game gives you you don't carry in your
existing loot you don't carry in your
load
your weapons and your level none of that
applies to this mode which doesn't feel
like a complete Mia Copa on Ubisoft part
it doesn't necessarily feel like an
acknowledgement of yeah we've kind of
screwed up the game since it first
launched but it does feel like a nod
towards those players who have grown
frustrated by this sort of just lack of
fairness and the way the game operates
you can now jump in and play something
that's totally independent from all of
those issues that players have been
experiencing up to this point yeah
someone who hasn't even played much of
the base game or at least the regular
you know like previous version of the
division like the main game I this
actually threatens to pull me back in
more than anything else you know like I
I really like from my perspective I want
to ask you more about this yeah it seems
like survival mode grounds the game
itself in the setting a little more you
feel like you know between the cold of
New York winter like post-apocalyptic
kind of really actually fighting it out
on the streets makes more sense for this
mode than it did in the original which
felt much more like this loot fest where
I was you know mid maxing my weapons and
gear it didn't feel like it fit this one
feels like it's a little more you know
rooted in the setting is that like I
mean again you played a little bit that
kind of your impression so far I think
that's exactly right I think it
definitely leverages the sort of
narrative hook of the game and the
setting as well because yeah as you
pointed out I mean the game as a whole
is set in a wintery New York City during
a sort of post pandemic setting you know
everything about it screams this is
gonna be a survival based experience and
yet the main game is just like you know
bullets bunch enemies and restock crates
everywhere littered around the world
like it didn't really thumb Attica Lee
mesh at all this definitely takes those
ideas and and turns them into gameplay
so yeah from the moment you start you
your character is actually freezing like
there is a temperature gauge on screen
at all times when you're outside of a
safe house saying hey you need to get to
a fire barrel or find a new safe house
or find new clothing to keep this meter
from depleting too quickly and in
addition to that you will grow hungry
and when you start you are already
infected and that will progressively
grow worse over like the longer it takes
you to beat survival the worse off you
are by the end so if you
take too long your health suffers um so
it's totally doing all these really new
and interesting things that mechanically
are not only new but thematically in
line with the universe and so like
correct me if I'm wrong you can do PvE
or PvP in this mode right yeah and it is
a hard select at the beginning is unlike
the dark zone where you can kind of go
in and do whatever you want you are
actually selecting PvE mode or PvP mode
and basically only difference is can you
shoot other human players or not okay
and I honestly think that PvE is a
little more interesting what's kind of a
bummer at least what I've seen so far is
you can't actually trade items so like
if I have a lot of painkillers and
someone's dying I can't be like here are
some painkillers person I found in the
world which is to me the whole reason
why you pick PvE so you can partner
together so you can help each other out
you can make it to the dark zone where
like the antivirals that you're hunting
for are located so it's a shame that you
can't share items but I mean you still
have to fight NPC's in both modes so for
me
choosing PvP just feels like it would be
even more punishing and like I'd rather
just have a posse and like group up and
take on the world together personally
yeah I'd rather do PvE I feel like as
much as like some human players will be
good at this and understand what makes
this mode unique I feel like I trust AI
more to bind my like to like facilitate
the experience I want to have with the
specific mode and maybe that's why I
kind of had some problem the base game
the division where you know like the
dark zone
dark zone yeah when the dark zone I was
kind of having problems with like I feel
like a lot of times my experience was
hinging on whether other players were
like understood it not maybe I didn't I
don't know but uh there's actually funny
you mentioned the fire barrel like back
then because he ran up to a fire blower
barrel right as you said that but like I
said timing yeah I don't know I've been
playing like I play a little bit of a
lucha trolls Skyrim remastered on a ps4
and like the mods like that let you
actually have cold survival things I
actually like that for the same reason
it routes it in Skyrim or as that is why
I want to play this now because this
seems like I'm not just it's not just
this like loot grind disguised as this
post-apocalyptic third-person shooter it
feels like it's this you know again
survival based it makes sense within the
world that they've they painted for me
and I really want to try that out I
don't know whether I'll have time
but I am really curious on as you said
you're like kind of moving toward the
center of the map just the whole time
right like as you're getting your
weapons like going like maintaining your
heat your temperature there's there's a
lot of like a risk/reward factor right
like you could just keep be lining
toward the center but you might not have
good enough gear later on if you ignore
like tangential stuff to like actually
fight like the harder enemies toward the
center did you have you experienced that
much yet I haven't actually made it to
the center yet it's actually really hard
it's a demanding mode which I like I
like that about it that your first
couple rounds are going to be you
learning how to survive in this world
and learning what demands you're facing
but yeah I think the sort of crux of the
gameplay hook is that risk reward loop
of yet do you push further out into the
periphery and risk freezing to death in
order to get better gear or do you try
to just take what you have and run to
safety you know and and hope that it's
enough that's really the core question
driving this entire experience you
definitely have to hunt a little bit you
start with basically nothing you have a
pistol and like bare-bones
outfit and like basically no supplies or
equipment to supplement like if you get
shot or you get or you're bleeding out
or something you can't fix that unless
you've already hunted down and acquired
the the proper materials or gone to a
crafting bench and made them so to some
extent you have to hunt for stuff when
you decide to make a break for the dark
zone that's up to you but that to me is
what makes it really interesting and
also why I really want to cooperate with
other people
sure and then just like to clarify like
what parts of it our procedural
generation just where enemies are placed
or where items are placed and then the
map is a static every time right yes so
you start in a different location every
time and there are different safe houses
scattered and this to be clear you're
using the entire map like it is the
entire city of New York is is where this
is taking place it's just in the middle
of a giant storm so it doesn't quite
look or feel like it normally does if
you've beaten the campaign or or just
gone back to kind of grind out some
other side missions like you're in that
same space game space but it now feels
very different because there's this
blinding storm that really limits
visibility and it changes sort of there
are no civilians it's only rioters
around like to maybe pick you off as
they like they kind of materialized out
of the snow and start shooting at you
it's it's actually pretty intimidating
and the other really cool thing is when
another human player dies that will
actually pop up on your screen and say
like sixteen agents remaining and it's
just this kind of ominous reminder that
yeah oh yeah this is really tough and
like all these other humans that I'm in
here with are dying off yes it's kind of
like Hunger Games issue and you see like
Cher name pop up in the sky you're like
oh man like right I'm gonna die whether
by enemy or by the environment and I do
like the idea this probably sounds
cliche but the world itself is an enemy
now and that's really cool to me because
you could just die like and without even
seeing another person you can freeze to
death you can starve to death you can
die of thirst you can be killed by the
infection yeah like everything's working
against you you have to actively try to
keep yourself alive at all times you
know how many human players populate 24
24 which feels like too few honestly
you're gonna say like if it takes place
on the whole map and like how often do
you even see people that is is there
like markers work to where people are
great question because no and I feel
like player density is a big issue for
games like this I mean h1z1 I think did
it really well and this is very similar
to that game for anybody who's played it
so I would honestly I hope that they
upped the player density I hope that
they allow more people to jump in on a
particular game because there I've
actually I haven't had a problem running
into people so far surprisingly despite
the fact that it takes place on a huge
map but there isn't any way to track
anybody your best bet is to go to safe
houses because that's where other
players are most likely to appear right
yeah but in a way I kind of like going
in blind because as mike has pointed out
the matically that makes sense like your
radios down you have nothing so how in
this universe would you be tracking
other people so I appreciate that at
least makes sense even if it does make
it tougher to like partner up with
friends or something yeah that sounds
really cool it is it is really cool like
I said I really appreciated that it's a
standalone experience you basically just
have to make it to the very first safe
house in the game and once you're there
there's like a separate elevator you can
walk over to and then it just jumps you
right into survival so you have to beat
the opening tutorial but other than that
you can just jump right in so if you
made it halfway through the campaign and
thought this sucks like give up screw
this bullet sponge nonsense you and if
you still own the game you can jump back
in and play survival and it's just a
completely different experience and
you're free to do that at any time so
about you Jake
I mean you play it a decent amount of
the base game do you plan on coming back
actually when we started I was like no
I'm not gonna go back and playing
division but after hearing you talk
about it that actually sounds really
cool that like what Mike was saying that
is what I was hoping for and that's kind
of what I thought it was gonna be based
on the trailers that they showed like it
seemed very much about survival
like you run into other players just
kind of naturally and like you'd shoot
or not you fight or not fight and the
when they got rid of all that it just
didn't seem that interesting but now
that that sounds pretty cool and I got
most importantly it eliminates all of
the problems that people have had with
the game over the past few months I mean
again I think a lot of people got really
frustrated with the game and walked away
and are kind of bitter about some of the
changes that were made or even how the
base you know the end game the original
end game operated so this side steps all
of that by turning the game into this
completely other separate standalone
mode which is probably a very smart
decision given that they were having
such a difficult time salvaging the
experience that was already there I do
really like that its standalone in the
sense that I don't know I have this
thing with like loot games that if I'm
not playing it from the start that I'm
gonna be behind and I like the idea that
can jump into this and it's almost like
I'm starting fresh for everybody
yeah totally new that's just more
psychological in my part but yeah I am
it's also excited to try this out
there's been one game that I've only
ever put like two hours into it and I've
been wanting to play like the base game
as well first since it release in March
I think it was when you reviewed it it
means good yeah the end game is like
broken and stupid in the dark zone just
didn't pan out the way we hoped it would
but I still stand by the fact that the
campaign is like is diverse and
difficult and fun with friends and yeah
like I don't know I really like the
original campaign even though most
people have kind of moved on and that at
this point
cool so like again we have talked about
us a couple of times before in the lobby
but now that you've actually played it
you're not gonna do a full review but
like it's why we want to bring you on
today like I know you've only played a
brief time but like what's your like
verdict so far you still pretty it
sounds like you're pretty like excited
to try more yeah this is the kind of
experience that you you only learn more
like it's tough because you kind of go
in blind and that's part of the fun
right I think not knowing how things are
gonna work or what's sort of waiting
around the next corner or how you solve
the problems presented to you and
learning that as part of the excitement
so right now I'm absolutely like drawn
in like I'm sold after my first couple
playthroughs of like okay I enjoy this I
want to see where this is going I want
to
how to solve these problems this is new
and exciting and interesting for the
division so I'm really enjoying my time
so far it does feel like its own kind of
experience apart from the division I
mean if it weren't for you know some of
the UI and the voiceovers and stuff it
would almost feel like a completely
different game altogether so I'm
enjoying it yeah it is a little too
early for me to say like it's good go
buy it but I mean if you own a copy the
division and this sounds in any way
interesting like I've really enjoyed the
mattress that I've played so far how
long are these matches cuz they sound
like they could go on for a very long
time yeah in in some of the marketing
material they said a match can last up
to two hours and I'm guessing they
wouldn't last much longer than that
because eventually you will just succumb
to the infection like if you don't beat
it quick enough just die I mean that the
clock is always ticking on you because
you start already infected waiting to
get to the drop zone and get picked up
so if if you beat it like say like an I
don't know thirty minutes I don't know
if that's like reasonable at all does
the game keep going like do other people
still try to get there do you need to
complete it together
I believe you can win without other like
you can just escape on your own I don't
think like everyone in the match has to
finish for the round so where you are
going at your own pace it's not like
you're waiting for everyone to die or
whatever yeah correct okay you're kind
of doing your own thing but if you want
to or are able to you can help out other
players who are in the game with you
cool I'm really looking forward to that
like well it reads that detail just like
kind of feeling more at home and that
we're not at home but more connected to
that world yeah I think what's much more
hostile this time around which I really
like
as the divisions survival mode DLC it is
out now you can download the update
today on Xbox one or PC and then
December 20th I believe it'll be
available on ps4 for any players wanting
to play on that platform so let us know
if you plan on getting back in the
division if you've been playing for a
while how this changes up your what you
think of the game and let us know in the
comments below